hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream number 66 is it 66 yep february 6
66
february and it is february 6 i was
going to mention that just so somebody
seeing this maybe in the future would
know when this was done
it's always useful i guess we've covered
it we can just yeah pick that box right
there stamp is done now
there's some question as to whether or
not
we clash and i must say i
also i think you and i have a
disagreement about this but i also have
some question as to whether or not
two separate people clashing is a thing
and whether this is not some kind of
window into what it means for
for people to clash color-wise
whether or not what is some sort of a
window into what it would mean here's
the thing
we can all agree that there are certain
colors let's say that if you wear them
together they look
bad and somebody who sees you will think
that's not right and the question is
like if you took those two colors
and you were wearing one of them and
somebody else was wearing the other one
and they were sitting right next to you
on the subway
would somebody look and say those two
people clash or does the brain
file that clash is within one person in
other words it's an indication
of whether that person is chromatically
sensible or is it really something about
the universe doesn't want those two
colors together
yeah well i mean i think uh the question
is an interesting one
but i do think to the degree that
obviously within a person within it
within a a
choice that a single person has made we
agree that there is clashing possible
but i think it is
actually you're reading something about
intent actually when you are assessing
clash and so
two people sitting next to each other on
the subway is not the same category as
us sitting here in this room oh that's
interesting right
is some question of choice here at least
theoretically right even even though
actually we both uh we
showed up here having spent some time
together earlier today but not in the
clothes we're currently wearing
so um yes when you sat down i said oh i
i really like that shirt on you we might
clash
um and i'm not sure that we actually do
but i think um
i think it is possible for two people
who are choosing to present to the world
together to clash in a way that i would
not say necessarily that two
strangers on a train uh would be would
be said to clash i think i know how to
handle it oh we'll just tell the people
watching the podcast that they should
have no judgment about us in this case
because it is not
as if we chose to wear these things we
are much like people on a subway
yeah interesting so i will also say that
for those of you listening
not watching we have our our black cat
our eldest carnivore in the family
sitting here on the screen
and he goes with everything he does the
cat never clashes
yeah never never clashes he's not
thrilled about the conversation at the
moment but
he's not clashing um so okay we were
welcome
everyone thank you for being here we are
grateful for
uh for the audience and for the
remarkable reception we are receiving
in the world and we get really good
reception
[Music]
i don't know how many people we lost on
that that joke but it's probably worth
it maybe just me
oh that would be bad that would be great
let's avoid that okay so
um we're just going to make a couple
logistical announcements at the top of
the hour
talk a little bit about where we're
going today and then then launch in
okay so um as always
you are encouraged to stay with us if
you're watching on youtube for the q
a afterwards and you can ask questions
uh for the live stream q
a which we did not post the audio
podcast only this main uh
hour hour plus goes to the audio podcast
on super chat on youtube either in this
first hour or in the second hour
you can also get access to a private q a
on my patreon or access to
um conversations longer conversations
with
brett on his and uh you had one of those
this morning already and you have
another one tomorrow morning yep we
almost solved it
wow i know i know we didn't quite get
there so join quickly before
next month we're to nail down the final
details of the new civilization we will
all inhabit and i think you all are
going to love it
it's uh it's going to be good if i
didn't know you i would find that
terrifying
right i'm just kidding yes we're still
we're still working i would think so
it's all being done in pencil
in pencil okay um let's see what else
um you can email darkhorse.moderator
gmail.com for logistical questions like
how do i ask a question on how do i pose
a question or where can i get a fancy
dark horse mug
right at store.darkhorsepodcast.org yeah
and clarification yes q a is found on
heather's patreon private q a private q
a but it's both of us
yes yes it is both of us once a month
um last sunday of the month um but we do
live public q as after every single live
stream every
every um week so
where we're gonna go today we're gonna
spend some time um
talking about meat a little bit about
meat uh a follow-up to
a comment i made last week we're gonna
talk about why and when you should
follow the science
right um and where to and where to
and what to do when you find yourself
somewhere you really didn't expect what
to do if you catch the science which
yes like our dog always after the deer
what would you do if you actually caught
one of them you have no idea
um talk a little bit about um the new
york times uh
suggestion this week about perhaps
editing or moderating encrypted chat
programs
uh discuss an analogy that you have
about the null hypothesis
uh maybe talk a little bit about a new
uh new sony camera
setting situation by which we can get
gain entry into some evolutionary talk
that sounds really terrible but it will
be more interesting i think
it really will be and then um i want to
finish by talking about
snakes and mangroves and uh there is a
connection between the two that is not
obvious but
um this is you know this is the kind of
stuff that i want to be talking about
all the time and because you know we are
obviously not going to get to
so much of what is actually going on in
the world which for many months we were
spending a lot of time on just like
responding to what happened this week
in the world um as always if you would
like
our take which you know we may just say
i just don't know enough to say
um you can ask questions super chat and
we'll um we'll try to get to those
questions
snakes and mangroves i don't uh aside
from the obvious i don't i don't
i don't know what's coming so this will
be interesting yeah so you know uh
non-teaser non-hint really um it's not
about snakes in mangroves
um yep all right i'm working on it okay
good
and i will give i will give you more and
see if you can i mean you you once i
talk about the snake angle will be able
to make the connection i hope so yeah um
all right
so um before we talk a little bit about
meat though
uh it feels like something is breaking
loose
in the conversation and the visibility
of the conversation around lovely
hypothesis does it not
in service of that i would say hey zach
you can show
our screen here for the moment this is
in the telegraph today
which is a british paper did the coven
19 virus really escape from wuhan lab
fingers have been pointed at bats
pangolins in a shuttered wet market but
what if the truth is altogether more
alarming this um published today by matt
ridley annelina chan
elena chan being one of the scientists
who has been tirelessly working
on trying to figure this out uh and
um and there was also a piece an
editorial i think in wapo and washington
post this week
yep and uh yeah
there there have been three i think
there was another one but i've forgotten
which publication it was in um but
anyway yes something is
clearly breaking loose um and
i think this has multiple levels of
relevance because on the one hand
there's the question and i was
very pleased to see matt and alina
address this in terms of the answer to
where this virus came from
is i think they say it's maybe the most
important question of the century and
i agree with them i don't think we fully
understand what we will be able to
derive from the answer to that but i
know
full well there will be important
aspects once we know
whatever the answer is if it's a natural
origin we need to know that because for
one thing
if it's a natural origin it's a very
bizarre natural origin it doesn't fit
any of the others that we know about
and so we will learn something about
what is possible
that is very important on the other hand
well it
the the originally proposed
hypothesis which is presented as fact
and you can't question it
right for sars kobe 2 was originated in
a bat
ended up in the wet market through
smuggled pangolins yes
which is you know clear there's just
there's just no evidence for this at
this point practically or there's a lot
of evidence against
yes but the origin story that um
is the mainstream origin story for sars
kobe one
is parallel to that and so like you know
it it seems
it seems like a reasonable thing to have
thought at first assuming that all of
this is organic and these are good faith
players that sars kobe 1
was originally in a horseshoe bat and
then showed up in a market
in um in a secondary you know having
having spilled over into a secondary
host in
um what some kind of kind of run uh palm
civet palm civet yeah home civic so this
was a wet market situation
right um but it still doesn't match
okay so i must say there are questions
about the original
what's ours kobe one and and the
proposal on service
cov2 do not match the evidence there's
something new going on here because in
sars ko v1 you did have
rapid evolution of this pathogen in
humans that's one thing that you would
absolutely
i don't want to say it's required
because i could imagine
you know in the way that birds and
people or pigs and people exchange
certain viruses back and forth it's
possible that you're part of a
long-standing system
and therefore the evolution has already
taken place at the point something
uh crosses over but in this case that's
not what appears to be going on and so
the idea of a virus that is well adapted
to humans to to begin with and therefore
takes off like a shot
is unique and unlike sarsko v1 right so
just just to be
clear about what you're saying i think
there are a lot of sort of dangling
modifiers in there
um this is the second trick to which you
have referred both on bill maher and
many times on
on on here and maybe even in joe rogan
when you're on on rogan last june
um the you know the the one trick is
of zoonotic diseases is switching hosts
and there you know there are a lot of
additional tricks
but the other major trick that we saw
with sarsko v2
is well that we see with anything that
becomes pandemic
is then being able to rapidly spread
between humans between
individuals between crown specifics of
the species of the new
host into which it is spilled over and
that will almost always take
time to evolve that capability in the
pathogen will take time to evolve
and what was so notable about sarsko v2
is that it was it had both tricks on
board as soon as we started
hearing about it or there's something
that we've missed or there's something
that we've missed sure
um okay so
a there's the speed b there's the
evidence it would leave
in the phylogeny right so if you do the
phylogeny you would have diversity that
we don't see
here in the initial thing so it's
possible there's some phase of the story
we just don't know if this is a natural
origin story
you know the thing that gets said is it
could have circulated
somewhere else that we still haven't
detected
and then you know somebody takes a train
and they end up in wuhan and we notice
it and it's already adapted because it's
been
uh circulating and evolving but the
point is okay
there's been an awful lot of pressure to
find evidence of that there is no
evidence of that yet
and so what we are left with is an is an
anomaly one way or the other and the
answer to that anomaly
is vitally important to figuring out
what to do
and people have not alina and matt
were very good about pointing out that
it's there though they don't say what
the value is
but there's that and then there's the
other question which is more obvious
which is if this is a lab leak
even if it didn't do anything for us
with respect to
uh preparing and fighting uh kovit going
forward
it would do something for the next
pandemic which we are likely to cause by
the same route
if if lab leak it is likely to have been
at least partially a result of the gain
of function
and research that involves serial
passaging and if
that research continues um
lab leaks are likely to continue to
happen down the road right and in fact
one of the things that shows up in a lot
of the
good reporting on this is that there is
a long
catalog of accidents where things have
leaked out of labs this is unprecedented
in one regard and in another way it's
completely mundane
um you know that nothing about covet is
mundane but the fact of something having
leaked out of a lab would be anything
but new
yeah and i guess i mean just one more
important distinction between sarsko v1
and series cov2
is precisely that sorry's kobe 1 did not
become a global pandemic it precisely
lacked
being very good at that second trick it
was able to move between humans
but not super fast and not nearly as
effectively as sars kobe 2
seemed to come out of the starting gates
being able to do so it burned out which
is another
typical thing so you know typical thing
for a
natural zoonotic spillover exactly
so but to the second point i don't want
to take too much time here but
there's two issues happening in parallel
one
is what the hell is covid and
why does it behave the way it does and
where did it come from super important
covered or serious
the disease or the pathogen i was
calling it covet just because
the you know the pandemic the the impact
on people is
the important thing but obviously the
causal agent is
you know is where the evidence lives
but totally separately from that
this story as you point out something
new is breaking loose
this is a very rare example
of the uh the gated institutional
narrative not having effectively
silenced
some uncomfortable awful possibility
that needs to be investigated and so
that exceptional fact what it is that
allowed
this discussion to actually move in the
direction of something reasonable and
although those of us who believe lab
leak is a possibility differ
i believe widely on how likely we think
it is
um it's also worth noting though that in
ridley and chan's uh
piece in the telegraph today they finish
by listing
a whole number of virologists
and epidemiologists who in the early
days
were saying very very absolute things
about uh this it not being a possibility
and um in fact i believe i did not
actually go back and
check to make sure this is true but that
like 27 authored paper
that was published in i think nature
early than pandemic saying there's no
way this is natural zoonotic spillover
there's no way this is a lab leak
um are now when asked
by jan or ridley and and um they say and
are willing to go on the record saying
well yes it's a possibility yeah and so
we are seeing
we are also seeing a move on the part of
the scientists some of whom were
involved in participating
in silencing this and silencing actual
scientific inquiry in the first place
so you know great that we are actually
people are actually now saying yes it's
a possibility
but i would really not i would really
not want to lose the history here
that that those people who have been
involved and you know
it persists you know we're still being
called conspiracy theorists and
anti-scientific for
questioning what the authorities have
already declared is true and stamped it
on everyone's foreheads
um like that that is still alive and
well and it's still dominant
but sort of slowly behind the scenes
you're beginning to see movement
by the actual scientists who never
should have come out as certain as they
did in the first place that was
big part of the problem yeah it wasn't
certain then and there was a
rush to circle the wagons around that
certainty which caused i think a lot of
people who were paying slightly less
attention to believe it actually was
certain which made it very difficult to
i mean yeah as as i said on mar as i've
said here you know because because the
possibility of a lab leak came out of
trump's mouth
you know half the country immediately
said no way no how and you know
and the media facilitated that
mainstream media said oh if he said it
you know orange man says it it must not
be true guess what guys that's not only
not the way science works it's not the
way reality works
it doesn't matter who says it if it's
true it's true yeah and you know this
story is one
as with all of these stories the nuanced
position that follows
the evidence and extrapolates
responsibly from it
lands on a slate of conclusions that
doesn't belong in some camp
right you know is there a possibility of
a lab leak here
yes the evidence so far points in that
direction and not the other direction
but not conclusively
on the other hand does that mean that
this is a chinese virus
no there's an awful lot of evidence
pointing to the fact of an international
failure of the proper safety it's an
international
collaboration virus yes an international
collaboration virus yeah and so the
point is you know this isn't going to
play for one team or the other and
you've you know you've been fed
two possibilities and but they're both
wrong
certainly and the the right thing is
going to
involve having to parse these details
but okay
actually i actually want to muddle this
a little bit more politically for people
because i think i think that actually
will help
people lose their but i'm on the blue
team therefore i believe this i'm on the
red team therefore i believe this
stuff which is that gain of function
research
has been contentious in the scientific
community since it began
and it became it it rose to the top of
people's concerns sufficiently
that in i think it was 2000 i can't
remember 2014 or 2015 that is during the
obama administration
um there was a moratorium at the federal
level in the united states
put on gain of function research in the
u.s
that stopped then now that actually
probably facilitated
some of this collaboration that then
moved it off offshore
which we're not going to go there right
now but
that moratorium that uh the obama
administration put on exactly this gain
of function research was in fact lifted
by the trump administration at the end
of his first year in 20 at the end of
2017. and so which team are you playing
for now
like how how does that stuff make you
feel
about who the good guys are and who the
bad guys are guess what again reality
doesn't care what you think
or the politics of the people involved
or whether or not they're right or wrong
about other stuff
you know this virus has an origin and we
don't know what it is yet
but you know a year ago we were already
you know as you say the wagons were
already being circled on
there was only one story that we are
going to talk about says the scientific
community
we are scientists we are in the
scientific community and
we never wanted to be part of a
situation
which says ah you don't need to know the
evidence but we've already decided what
the truth is
nope not science and if going forward
you want this never to happen again you
need to empower
people to actually um deal with the a la
carte conclusions rather than signing up
for a slate and a team
right the whole the whole point is that
this is not a clear story this is a
screw up at multiple levels
we know that it's a screw up at multiple
levels even if it is natural origin
right
the fact is we suddenly are all aware
that these viruses are being enhanced in
laboratories
this is an obvious hazard whether or not
it actually spilled over from the lab
this time
but you absolutely have to have a
free scientific discussion that then is
allowed to impact policy
without polarizing this because the
polarization is going to have played a
huge
role if this is a lab leak it's going to
have played a huge role
in this the mother of all self-inflicted
wounds
yeah right yep yep yeah all right
now let's get to the show oh right okay
okay i forgot that we were actually on
camera
yeah um excuse me yeah um so
yes our dinner conversations do sound
like that and for the most part our two
teenage sons
are uh ready to ready to talk ready to
do it so
the dog not so much she's mostly
interested in watching what's on her
plate and
see if any of it goes to the floor i've
misunderstood her intent though yeah
so our 2d inch sons again as i mentioned
last week
zachary our 16 year old who is also the
producer of darkhorse
who's working tirelessly to put together
an excellent show
so let's start i want to start with a
correction clarification from last week
on the inflammatory properties of red
meat which is um something that i said
is kind of a throwaway line when i was
talking about
the effects of diet on covet and from
this rishi at all
2020 paper which i post from the show
notes which is to say i just i
have the links in the youtube
descriptions and in the
podcast descriptions as well the line
from the paper is for example
plant-based foods are likely to support
a gut microbiome capable of inducing an
appropriate level of anti-inflammatory
response in the host
in contrast to a pro-inflammatory immune
response
elicited by the gut microbiome with
individuals consuming food products such
as wheat
red meat and alcohol thereby resulting
therefore boy thereby resulting in
chronic gut inflammation
so um this was not the focus of
the research that i had done and so i
sort of said it and as i said it i
thought
i'm not sure um and the reference that
they cite reishi at all site is
another 2020 paper luthra gupta sarma
and gupta sarma
called inflammation begets
hyperinflammation in covet 19
diet derived chronic inflammation
promotes runaway acute inflammation
resulting in cytokine storms
but it turns out that that paper as um
as well done as it is in many ways and i
just i
went to it and read it last night or
this morning
that paper merely asserts the
association it doesn't even have a
reference it just
asserts the association it provides it
so it provides no evidence now that's
not to say that there aren't
a lot of papers out there that do
exactly um claim to find this
association
um but this actually wasn't one so this
was a reference that didn't
didn't actually belong there as a
reference and so this is just that you
know i'm taking
a moment here to say you know this is
this is again also also
not how science is supposed to be done
when you have a reference it's supposed
to actually point you to
the evidence for the thing that's being
claimed and when you are making
and when there is a claim in your paper
that is surprising or
new and there's no reference that is
your indication of the world
this is your the author's idea so
there's a reference there
went there just an assertion um not you
know not
scientifically deducible from from what
was written so i was asked about this in
our q a which again not on the audio
podcast but in the youtube q a
afterwards
appropriately and what i said then was
that i actually believe that the
category red meat
is not is a bit of a junk category not
to use like a phylogenetic term
um it's and then at the very least it's
often um
what i said was i believe that to the
extent that eating red meat is
inflammatory that this is going to be
about these hyper novel
farming techniques animal farming
techniques that we're using and that
you're likely to have the closer to the
ancestral diet of the meat that you're
eating
that animal had while it was alive the
less likely it is to cause problems for
you when you eat it so
not just grass-fed which for those of
you who don't know doesn't actually mean
that the animal was allowed to eat grain
you know
grass-fed beef was not eaten grass until
the very end of its life it has to say
grass-fed and
finished and you know why wouldn't you
grass feed a cow for its entire life if
you grass-fed it well
you feed it grain at the end and it's
going to cause a
weight gain very quickly which means you
can sell it for more but it also means
that animals sicker at death and
probably causing
you problems when you eat that meat so
grass-fed and finished beef i i argued
in the q a
is likely to have fewer inflammatory
properties
i stand by that that that i believe is
is true um
but maybe an even bigger issue of the
junkiness of the category
red meat is simply like whole red meat
versus processed red meat
so um this um there is there is a lot
out there and i'm not going to spend
much time here but several papers
several good papers
i skimmed a bunch of them today do
distinguish between these categories
sufficiently that in 2015 the
international agency for research on
cancer
issued a press release on the results of
the evaluation of the carcinogenicity of
red and processed meat
i'm quoting here from a domingo nadal
2017 paper
based on the accumulated scientific
literature the consumption of red meat
was classified as
probably carcinogenic to humans and
processed meat as
carcinogenic to humans so
um and you know the why processed meat
is going to have a lot to do with the
nitrates and nitrites
um and yeah maybe for another time we we
can go there but
um also there's a potential supply chain
issue here referencing back to our
last live conversation yes but process
meets are almost certain to be much much
farther
from you know between uh farm and table
and therefore you know breakdown of
uh valuable molecules the conversion
into
some semi-random or arbitrary set of
other molecules
i don't know if this is true or not
that's a prediction but no i think
that's
it's it's quite possible i think that's
right and it reveals
also you know this finding that we
talked about last week about
long supply chains for foods being
correlated with things like metabolic
disorders
um there are likely to be a lot of
reasons for that and this is gonna
this this therefore i think this the
longer your supply chain for food the
less healthy you are likely to be
is actually one of these few like
actually that's a snapshot rubric that i
think is going to stand for all sorts of
reasons there can be all sorts of
ways that that is true and so far at
least i haven't thought of any
things that would run in the other
direction yeah i mean
at one level you know you and i um i
think
thematically are on board loosely with
the idea of
paleo diet the sense that our diets um
the more removed they are from ancestral
uh the less good they're going to be but
very loosely paleo
yeah that's the thing paleo is a narrow
phenomenon is wrong
um but anyway loosely speaking the more
ancestral your diet the more likely it
is
to be healthy for you and the point is
long supply chain introduces an
arbitrary number of new phenomena some
of which may not matter but the chances
that something that matters will be
between you
and uh you know and the farm is high
and so yeah i see this as as likely and
um there you know probably ultimately
there'll be a catalog
of phenomena and you know it's different
when you buy the
food from the farmer at the farmer's
market right
yeah um let's see you prompted something
for there hey you've got a hemiparent
yes i do
wow a true bug a true bug right here in
the podcast probably not visible on
camera though
um oh boy i was just gonna
what was i gonna say in response to you
huh supply chains
yeah i i'd paleonto i kind of lost the
hamilton drew my attention and now he's
making a move on my computer
um oh i know about um
you know so there's a lot to say about
paleo diet as well
um let's not let that hemetron actually
into any of the ports of my computer
that seems like a mistake
um you know that that's where the term
computer bug came from
originally probably not a mipter and
something smaller like an ant but
uh but computers were at a whole
different scale right right
yeah i remember i remember those
computers my father having been a
computer scientist
in the 70s and 80s before that these
were programmed with
yeah oh with cards and stuff you've got
wires you've plugged in large wires
between
different places um okay so
the the problem with paleo diet you know
sort of trademark paleo diet is that it
imagines a single past for all humans
and that there is also only one
environment of evolutionary
adaptedness uh that is the one to which
we are adapted
and you know the whole the the premise
one of the premises of our book
hunter gatherer's guide to the 21st
century is
that yes we are hunter-gatherers we we
were hunter-gatherers and that means
um evolutionarily speaking we still are
by that logic we are also
fish right and we are also reptiles and
we are also mammals and we are also
primates and monkeys
and apes and humans and within humans
yeah we're hunter-gatherers but we're
also agriculturalists and we're also
post-industrialists so we are all of
those things and we are adapted
to varying degrees to all of these
things and that you know
the parts of us that we retain from our
fish ancestry that have
uh been unchanging since then are really
the the word in evolutionary biology is
basil and
um you know you would tend to hear it
said primitive but
it's a word we try to avoid because it
has these connotations about it
um but you know those those very basal
characters like having
um like like having the kind of
circulatory system we have
um aren't going to change and um
and then but once you get to mammals and
we get the origin the evolution of a
four-chambered heart
um you know that's somewhat newer and
yet once you know once a four-chambered
heart evolves
actually twice separately in mammals and
in
either birds or birds and dinosaurs
depending on probably
it's hard to tell but probably birds and
dinosaurs um like
there's never any reversals and so it's
like it's really going to stick now
also agriculture 10 to 12 000 years ago
old or so evolved separately
convergently in
several different places around the
world yes mesopotamia which is the thing
we all learn about in elementary school
but also in the new world at least a
couple of times in china a couple of
times in
in in several places um
and it doesn't seem to ever reverse
people don't go people don't go back
and so we are almost all of us
descendants for 10 to 12 000 years of
farmers as well
which means we it's not that we're not
adapted to grains no that's not right
that's that's just not right you know
what this is
unrelated to the diet issue but do you
know what characteristic i learned
this week is a a holdover from our
aquatic past
no i don't dad jokes turns out
all right that one worked pretty well
also puns yes
well i so that was funny i didn't see it
coming at all which is
the way it should be um but i
immediately began to try to think of
okay like what fish up eternal care
because don't work and fishy fish unless
they have paternal characters you never
meet your dad
the dad jokes always fall flat yeah they
it it they have to be made at a distance
yeah socially distance tension there you
go
okay um so oh just one more thing
um no couple more things on this uh so
i've also got this
uh really good book actually which i
don't know if you can totally see
um called food and western disease
health and nutrition from an
evolutionary perspective a 2010 book by
stefan lindberg
and the setup for just the sentence that
he writes is
that um it's now thought that
inflammation is
a an important off sometimes causal
pre-existing condition for many cancers
now there is reason i think to think
that inflammation
is becoming this like catch-all category
and blamed for
maybe even more than it should be being
blamed for but
yes we have a growing understanding of
the role of inflammation um in in
human health and disease and what he
says here
um citing
citing one of his many many references
here is vegetarianism does not seem to
lower the risk of death from cancers
suggesting that meat is not a major
culprit and the reason that the way that
connects in
is if vegetarian diets and
omnivore diets i'm going to just put
aside entirely carnivore diets for the
moment
if vegetarian diets and omnivore diets
have equal rights of cancers
and if we are right that if the if the
current medical thinking is right uh
that
cancers are very often associated with
inflammation
then you would also imagine that red
meat is not particularly associated with
inflammation that it will be about
the diet of the animals you were eating
and the
degree of processing of the meat that
you're eating um
yeah i guess one one more thing here it
should be obvious
that talking about diet there's an
evolutionary perspective right
and while i'm sure there are people out
there going but you're not dietitians
you're not registered nutritionist
you've never even used a bomb
calorimeter have you
right once oh you did okay well then
that makes you
not an expert still once right i didn't
when
uh high school we did a thing okay
measured the amount of energy and i
piece of carrot wasn't it i don't have
something like that okay well oh maybe
maybe i have two i don't know you've
forgotten and i blocked it out
well i wouldn't have blocked it out but
i mean given that we actually for
two years of high school knew each other
and that probably would have been in
physics and
we were actually in physics together in
high school so maybe we used a bomb
calorimeter together
yeah anyway um point is
um obviously an evolutionary perspective
which most nutritionists and dietitians
actually lack
is absolutely necessary to understanding
what it is
that we are as humans and therefore what
it is that we should be eating
and it's not a very far leap to say
when people say to us but you're not
virologists you're not public health
experts you're not epidemiologists stay
in your lane go back and do evolutionary
stuff over here
back with the dinosaurs exactly you're
evolutionary biologists you must be
working on dinosaurs mustn't you
and like this evolution stuff guys
sorry if this offends you but it's
everywhere if you want to talk about
rocks or quarks cool
we will stay out of it but almost
everything else
is evolutionary and it is exactly the
lack of evolutionary understanding
that is likely at base causing some of
the confusion in the world i actually
god i heard i'm i'm not gonna name names
here but i heard
on a popular podcast uh a
you know a person who is has been put
forward as one of the experts in talking
about this pandemic based on this
person's research
was describing all of the animals for
sale at the market
in wuhan right and was you know
explaining like how many possible
you know spillover species there were
and they said
you know and here's a reading from
reading from a website
here's the species of wild animals and
here's the species of domestic or farmed
animals
and this person then paused and said
well i have no idea why they'd split
those lists up
but let's just proceed listening to this
i thought
if you honestly cannot understand why
it's important that wild animals and
domestic animals be
separated on a list when you were trying
to understand the possible origins of
this virus
and it is for instance known that
different
viral conditions evolve under captive
conditions
on for instance poultry farms then you
frankly have
no business pronouncing yourself as an
expert here yeah
like no business and that's not to say
that we won't all
you know even the most the people with
the most facility with evolutionary
thinking will miss
some of the evolutionary angles but you
need to have the perspective of
any time you change the conditions in
which something is potentially evolving
you create a new selective environment
and
you can expect that that will have
effects downstream
so um i'm going to introduce a concept
here which i think we've probably talked
about
here before which is uh path dependency
um
or what might be called historical
contingency in biology but
the idea is that certain things are the
way they are
not because it's the right way for them
to be but because there was a sequence
of events that led to it so you know
when you end up with the bicycle
actually depends on all the things being
in place you don't have a
functional one until you have dunlop's
pneumatic tire
which is the thing that kicks loose the
the safety bicycle in the end
but anyway the the thing that people
don't get is this
many many fields in and around biology
right including all of the fields of
medicine
came of age in parallel to a
new and crude understanding of evolution
and evolutionists did not
branch out into everything because we
didn't have the tools to look into for
example the cell
until very recently and so you have two
you have a
failure from both sides right you've got
fields that are
thoroughly evolutionary and in which an
evolutionary viewpoint is absolutely
essential but these fields proceed as if
darwin had never written the origin of
species you know
medicine and psychology being two places
where we do a tremendous amount of harm
for lack
of an evolutionary perspective but on
the other side you also find
that evolutionists have gotten used to
looking at the world they're very
focused on animal behavior they're very
focused at the phenomenal
phenomenological level they're hard to
interest into
mechanism and things like this because
our discipline
grew up where the power tools were
conceptual and they
you know the microscopes were crude and
so
in any case we are left with a world in
which a tremendous amount of harm
is done because nobody knows what
evolutionists are for
right including the evolutionists half
the time or maybe more than half the
time
so anyway it's about time we got over
this every field
um of biology is equally evolutionary
with i think one exception
the one it's ecology the one field that
we typically if we're gonna
get rid of the evolutionists and put
them in a separate building we usually
house them with the ecologist
can i just say that there are lots of
things that people try to cancel you and
me for
yeah and then occasionally you say stuff
where i think like
no one's gonna come after him for this
but like that's the actual like
potentially cancelable offense right
there
but here's the problem i'm right right
it's a kind of it's a kind of immunity
but the point is why why do i
think right is a kind of immunity
absolutely that's a shirt right there
okay but so why do i say ecology is not
as thorough and it's not that
it's tremendously useful to understand
evolution in order to do ecology an
evolutionary ecology
is a marvelous field that kind of never
got off the ground because classic
ecology
took up all the oxygen in the room but
the reason
that i say this is that creatures
are evolved right
combinations of creatures only sometimes
and
in a very different and lower level way
right so
ecology is the study of interactions
between creatures in general
interactions between creatures of
different species
and that there's lots of implications of
evolution in that process but the
relationship does not evolve the
creatures on both sides of the
relationship evolve
and so it's like one step back from
normal proper evolutionary logic
whereas cellular biology there's no
point at which you
you know you get down to things small
enough that evolution is no longer the
key way to understand them until you get
down to particles so you introduce this
by saying let me introduce
talking about path dependency and sort
of historical constraint philosophical
constraint um to me what you've just
landed on
is one of my absolutely favorite core
concepts in evolution which is that i've
shared fate
like if you are trying to understand
whether or not
um two things whatever they are um
are are you know are evolving together
have an evolutionary relationship do
they in fact have
shared fate an ecologist once said to
you
i was wondering whether i should mention
him so
why don't you say this and then i'll
finish what i was so i was sentenced to
death
uh after it's an amusing story i should
tell at some point but i nearly failed
out of graduate school in
prelims and it was a pre-trans fallacy
issue where i already understood
something that i wasn't expected to
understand and made it so that i would
not
answer questions in the way that they
needed to be answered to pass
the test so anyway it wasn't the only
flaw i was a hard student to deal with i
guess but
anyway i got sentenced to remedial
ecology which was like
torture right because these people
routinely said
crazy things from an evolutionary
perspective and i think the expectation
was that i would either learn to keep my
goddamn mouth shut
or that i would um say inflammatory
things and be driven into the sea
and either way problem solved but there
was this one instance
where um it was earl werner uh
and uh hi earl if you're watching um
anyway he
was lecturing on the basics of ecology
and i was sitting there in the back
trying not to scream and he said
he said um trees in a forest compete
like
cells in the body right and
no that's not true right
and precisely because of shared fate
right because the cells in your body
if you if one of your cells kills off
your body the other
cell dies they have shared fate if one
tree in a forest dies
the other trees may be affected it might
be positive it might be negative
the shared fate is so much looser yeah
it's not the same thing not only looser
but
there's just no basis for competition to
evolve between the cells in your body
because they have the same genome and
the only way that almost all of the
cells in your body reproduce is if they
act in a collaborative way such that
your gonads get a chance to
you know to produce a zygote you know
it's interesting actually
i never thought of like there was also
simultaneously in
in that department a move afoot to
demonstrate that competition was
um you know over represented in thinking
about ecology and cooperation was
underrepresented and as we have said
many times
you know humans in particular but really
all organisms um
are are both competitive and
collaborative and it depends on what
scale
you're looking at and what kinds of
interactions you're looking at but it
may be
you know that confusion may actually be
downstream
downstream of this imagining that
there's a perfect analogy to be made
between the cells in the body
and trees of forest because cells in a
body do not compete
like if if some ecologists are claiming
that they are the ones over
fitting competition to the world that's
not what's going on
and the trees in a forest are competing
actually and there's also collaboration
going on
you know especially for instance between
like oh we talked about this in our
private q a last week you know
the mycorrhizae the the fungus in the
soil
and in in collaboration with the risi
the roots of trees
that help both species do better in the
world
well it was a simultaneous overfitting
and underfitting
right it was imagining
competition in the cells that isn't
there
and it was making the competition in the
forest more benign by analogizing them
to a system that didn't have it
right yeah um you know i
pointed this out and the answer the
thinking was
well there are resources that have to be
divided there aren't enough resources
for every cell necessarily to have
everything it wants therefore there must
be competition
right and the point is actually
they're evolved to settle the
competition so it doesn't exist because
it makes
all of them you know a cell that dies
because it doesn't because it
decides not to take up resource but
whose genes are then transmitted by
the the gonads wins evolutionarily as
weird as that sounds i mean there are
trade-offs
but that's not the same as competition
yep but anyway
all to say evolution the logic of
evolution
although we are still new at it and we
have to get better at it but the logic
of evolution
is suffused through every biological
discipline equally
the number of people who die per year
because medicine and psychology has
failed to
grasp the implications of darwinism for
what they
do for a living is very large and anyway
we're we're awaiting this recognition
what gets in the way of it
is basically academic politics that you
are incentivized not to see these
connections because
it you know lets the hordes through the
gate right
we being the hearts i guess that's right
okay well that
that was item one i guess um we move on
to item b
yeah yeah um so
this section i have titled follow the
science except when we want you to
follow us and we're just going to
pretend it's because we're talking
science
one of the many executive orders that uh
biden introduced
president biden on january 21st
requires masks in national parks many of
you will have
heard this um reports news reports on
this tend to say masks required inside
and outside when in crowded areas like
overlooks
which you know that that would sounds
reasonable that sounds like
yes 100 when you're indoors with
strangers you should be wearing masks at
this point
and um you know in a really crowded
place
on overlooks oh okay sure um
but the actual eo
you can show my screen here for a second
zach um
is this is the executive order on
protecting the federal workforce and
requiring mask wearing
the um second paragraph
accordingly to protect the federal
workforce
and individuals interacting with the
federal workforce and to ensure the
continuity of government services and
activities
on duty or on-site federal employees
on-site federal contractors
and other individuals in federal
buildings and on federal lands
should all wear masks maintain physical
a distance and adhere to other public
health measures as provided in cdc
guidelines
um thank you zack so
that doesn't actually specify that they
they're not
that you're not required to wear a mask
if you're um away from people outside
and that worries me because
everyone who spends any time outside now
and you all should be
um especially if i mean you should be in
whatever form you can be but if you're
taking walks right now
i assume anywhere in the world and i
certainly assume anywhere in the united
states
um although there may be parts where
this is less so um
i can only speak to portland oregon and
from you know very brief moment last
week los angeles
um knows the social pressure that is
is being brought about by this pandemic
those of us like me who walk around with
a mask in my pocket
or depending in my hand ready to put on
but not on ready to put on a moment's
notice should it be necessary
get assessed as if we're all walking
around like sneetches that like
this is something i was talking about a
lot last summer it's like we are
star-bellied sneetches and sneetches
without
and there are indicators by which tribal
assessments are immediately made
and once made you are slotted into a
whole lot of other things
if you are not wearing a mask some
people's eyes will seem to say and i've
indeed seen some
i have not been involved in any of them
but i've seen some sort of yelling
altercations between people
if you're not wearing a mask that must
mean you also believe all this other
crazy nonsense
um you know red team stuff and
therefore we don't like you and you're
putting me at risk and you know i might
die
you know we quickly end up in hyperbole
and drama and performativity
and it's again anti-scientific
so um the assessment of like oh i get it
you're one of them no i'm i'm not one of
them like i'm not showing you my belly
you can't see if i have a star or not
based on whether or not when i'm outside
i don't have a mask on because guess
what the science
actually says is that there's almost no
risk of transmission for any of the
variants that we have yet seen for which
there is
our data that you can that this virus is
transmitting outside
look at all of those yes ill-advised
protests massive protests that became
riots you know daily in some places like
portland
last summer into last fall there were no
super spreader events that i know of
those things were happening outside even
with a lot of people
jammed together like that many of whom
were not wearing masks
there was very little viral transmission
this virus is not
spreading that way why probably two
reasons
probably more certainly two reasons one
it's about airflow
um and you know just just boundary
layers
and if you've got any sort of airflow
this this
the risk of getting the disease and the
risk of the severity of the disease
being high
once you get it are both density
dependent on how much viral
virus you were exposed to in the first
place so you get exposed to a little bit
maybe it even provides long-term a
little bit of immunity
to you and i'm not i'm not arguing that
you should go and try to get exposed to
a little bit of it but you know that
might actually be productive
um and you know again in service of just
getting some nuance going here
also vitamin d all right so airflow
and vitamin d you go all right
so are you ready for a bit more nuance
i am okay are you sitting down no you're
not sitting
for those of you listening rather than
watching i don't know if i'm sitting
down because it's pitch black
in the studio i'm also very short also
she's very short
yeah um no here's the here's the thing i
wanna
a let's say that uh
i you know let's hope this doesn't
happen but if we if we're stuck with
covid for good if we just have to learn
to live with covid
then we should develop a
way of um taking care of each other
relative to the virus without
um causing undue harm to ourselves
right and lots of things function like
this right the sophistication around
pathogens and washing one's hand and and
uh you know food service and all of that
these are mechanisms in which there is
shame directed at those
who misbehave and for good reason
because there should be a social penalty
for behaving badly another problem with
the current covid case with
respect to masks functioning as stars uh
on the bellies of sneetches
is that you've got two sides who look at
the other
as you're not taking care of us
right so the one side is saying you're
not keeping us safe from
covid you're going to spread it to us
because you're not wearing your mask so
put it on all the time broadcast that
you are one of the people who doesn't
want to spread covet
and the other side is saying you're not
taking care of us you're participating
in this authoritarian garbage
these people don't know what they're
talking about they're crashing the
economy and pretending it doesn't matter
you know all of these things and you
know there's a degree of truth in this
those who refuse to wear a mask
are definitely putting other people at
risk and those who are
imagining that if you're wearing a mask
you're a better human and therefore
wearing them all the time is a good idea
are participating in spreading
authoritarian garbage
now the problem the hyper nuanced issue
as we've been saying from the beginning
kova does not appear to transmit
outdoors
but that doesn't mean it couldn't learn
that trick
if it learns that trick how will it do
it it will do it because people are
careless outdoors and therefore some
you know virus that has a little bit of
a an edge in that regard for some reason
or another just
by luck will end up transmitting and
creating more cases and it'll get
built up the way every other adaptation
does so the point is
at the moment we appear to have a gift
that we have
a way to stay away from kovid and make
ourselves healthier
and make ourselves psychologically more
sound
and it works but if we treat it
carelessly we could lose it so
i think the right place for that line to
go is exactly where you said
if you're at an overlook outdoors and
it's crowded
you should wear your mask even though
the evidence says you're not going to
get covered there right
why because we have to protect the
loophole that we've got
right and so i want to see and in fact
we've lived by this but
if you are alone or just with people
that you're already in potting with
you should not be wearing a mask right
it's actually
potentially going to create more health
problems for you especially if it's
winter and you're otherwise all covered
up
and your face is literally the only
place that could be exposed to the sun
yep you want to be exposed to the sun
yeah for vitamin d reasons which are
very directly relevant to covet so
what you really want if we could just
take the politics completely out of this
question what you would really want
is for us to have a collective
discussion like the one that you and i
have been having since
march in which we built up a model
that would allow you to know whether
somebody was being an [ __ ]
or whether they were just simply taking
advantage of
a safe situation right in other words
as you pass somebody on the street right
the fact that you pass them on a street
and you don't pull
a mask up is not necessarily bad news
for one thing we can keep each other
safe
i sometimes hold my breath if i'm not
going to put a mask on to do something i
can hold my breath and know that i'm not
exhaling covid
if i have a three second you know
[Music]
situation where i pass through somebody
else's personal space
if we can pay attention to these things
you know the way we do all sorts of
stuff
about um public health and uh
you know disease transmission then we
don't have to
you know persecute people for doing
things that are actually perfectly safe
and
which they're doing them is not evidence
that they're insensitive it's evidence
that they
have a a good model
that's right that's right um
yeah so if you like i said if you cover
everything
on yourself while you're outside you're
probably not going to get covered that's
true but you're also not going to get
any vitamin d
and for similar reasons i would advocate
not
hiding yourself under thick layers of
sunscreen we've talked about this before
there is finally now after years of some
of us
thinking this and talking about it um
beginning to be evidence that slathering
yourself with sunscreen
and therefore reducing the level of
sunlight you get
is actually linked to some
late life illnesses that yes people who
don't slide themselves in sunscreen
end up with a little bit more skin
cancer i think is the result i didn't go
back and look at this but they're less
likely to die from it and they're less
likely to die of other diseases
and if you understand the you know
just as with the case of there being a
threshold dose of cova that you need
before you catch the disease there are
nuances
that frankly i don't know what the
mechanism is but it's quite clear that a
short break from the sun
gives you the ability to go back into
the sun
and that one can marshal this
in place of sunscreen and if you do that
then
you know does the slight increase
persist my guess would be it doesn't
yeah i i agree so
um in general i guess the the take home
here i mean there are several but is
that
i and i know you as well are not a fan
of reductive solutions to complex
problems
um so i've been preemptively skeptical
of pretty much all of these one word or
one phrase
the single note solutions the pandemic
you know hydroxychloroquine
vitamin d vaccines ivermectin like
really that's like it's just going to be
the one thing um
that seems like a very unnuanced and
uncareful approach
that said just on that list that i just
gave those four things
two of them um at least have incredible
promise
and almost no risk uh so vitamin d
and ivermectin ivermectin as uh
potentially prophylactic but
um uh almost certainly um
useful in reducing symptoms if you do
contract kevin 19
widely available not still under patent
apparently so quite inexpensive
um as as a as a treatment rather than
a you know a vaccine level prophylactic
for covid
uh is has has huge promise and i want to
say it's just beyond promise like it's
just being used in a lot of protocols at
this point
um and there are a lot of papers that
that show um
some you know that are beginning to be
out about vitamin d
um you know the the problem is um
you're better off getting all of your
stuff in the ancestral form
and so better than supplementing if
if you can at all to get out in the sun
and
you know i've heard this thing like well
i live so far north that there's no
chance of
getting enough vitamin d um at this
latitude and being healthy
during the winter guess what
people lived far north before there were
vitamin d supplements
now in some cases like in the north
atlantic they were
dealing with that by eating a diet rich
in cod for instance
there are there are historical solutions
to these problems it is
simply not possible that you need a
novel solution
to an historical to a problem that would
have been a problem for historical
people living
where you are living now if they didn't
have access to your novel solution
because people were just living and wow
and one caveat which is i was just about
to make the cover okay but no you go for
it
i just nope go for it all right the
caveat
is that there is no guarantee
that your um predispositions
match their level of solution yes right
actually that's a that's a step beyond
what i was going to say and
um you may not know actually so our um
our dear friend and former student and
also research assistant on our book
drew schneiderler um i think we took it
out i think it's not even a footnote
anymore but
exactly this on the question of actually
exactly vitamin d
and historical um living where you do
that
that in the far north pacific northwest
the farther north you go
you're told this thing and his point was
if you are from the population that
lived here
2 or 10 or 15 000 years ago
look to your ancestors wisdom look to
the cultural practices that they retain
and maybe those that ancestral wisdom
will apply to you
even if you are from a different
population as you know as he is even if
you're
anglo um living in ancestrally
obviously native american land maybe
their solutions will work and maybe
their solutions are actually particular
to the population um to which they
belonged
usually they won't be but sometimes they
will be and
like you you can just you can you can
decide this
carefully on like a step-by-step basis
without having to
reduce it to a single like wear a mask
wear sunscreen
you know yeah the key is you need the
model
you know so it's perfectly possible for
uh
light-skinned people to for the
ways that dark-skinned people deal with
uv
radiation near the equator to be um
insufficient for light-skinned people
faced with the same
hazard and vice versa it's possible for
the solutions that light skin people
have for vitamin d to be insufficient
for somebody with dark skin
if you move far enough north so you got
to pay attention to those things but the
point is if your model
says here's how vitamin d is produced
right and here's how i interface with
that model i you know
am either advantaged or disadvantaged
relative to vitamin d production
based on melanin content or something
like that you can at least figure out
whether you've got something you need to
correct for
and the ancestral way will do it or it
won't do it
in which case you might do something
else yep good
so rather than show you a couple of
these papers why don't we
we've got a lot more stuff that we
wanted to get through and we're already
at over an hour
so why don't we move on to a totally
different topic
you wanted to say a few things about
this
new york times piece from this week
which is titled
our private messaging apps the next
misinformation hotspot
zach i think you're going to want to
show this yeah we can scroll up and
look at the ad so this is a trial
balloon floated in the new york times
this week about now i don't want to
frighten people
but their claim is that misinformation
can be transmitted over private
messaging apps
and there's no way for us to prevent
misinformation
if we can't read what's in those apps so
things like signal
where your communication with your
intimate contacts
is encrypted and therefore unreadable by
authorities is a very um frightening
prospect
that is terrifying you know what we
might need actually is some sort of like
closed circuit television in every room
of everyone's house
they can just keep an eye on things keep
an eye on them and they can just
i mean probably you don't want everyone
being able to see everything in
everyone's room but like some
some authoritative body watching right
and what everyone is doing at all times
would be useful for this you can't know
when you're being watched so you have to
behave as if you're being watched how
about that
well i mean you know if you're in your
home you're being watched people are
shouting
panopticon at the sure at the screens of
their computers
um but okay this is an obscene
claim here that the fact that
misinformation can be spread on
encrypted text apps
is reason for us to potentially
eliminate the right to have such apps
and i would just point out
bad people serial killers okay
you know what serial killers have used
since the invention of roads
granola roads they've used roads right
you could say well the idea that serial
killers use
roads and serial killers are bad and we
all agree
to that and therefore we need to you
know have checkpoints on every road
no this is there is obviously such a
huge price to be paid
in freedom if to you know yes i have no
doubt that terrorists will use
paper they will use paper clips they
will use roads they will
eat food they will go outside they will
make vitamin d without your permission
they will do all kinds of things but um
in any case
um the fact that this article didn't
create more of an uproar i think is
troubling they are setting us up this
this article was certainly it's it's it
comes under the
sort of heading tech fix yeah techfix
right and you know the basics that's
probably one of their usual the basic
premise is
it of course we can kick people who say
false things off of
tech platforms but what about chat
and you know again as i would point out
every single time
this idea comes up those of you who
are focused on the fact that untrue
bad ideas circulate in an environment
and therefore
think shutting that down is a good idea
without giving a thought to the question
of
how do you distinguish wrong things
from novel things how do you take the
next big idea which is still not
understood
by people to be true you know what would
have happened for example
to the lab league hypothesis if that
authoritarian
entity whatever it is had been able to
shut down what it can
considered a conspiracy theory which was
actually just an obvious hypothesis in
need of test
and how many of those are we living
downstream of right and how many of
those have we had
the proper inquiry shut down because
somebody
appointed themselves uh the truths are
and in fact i believe truth tsar is
proposed in this absurd article
no yes no well it's certainly proposed
in
yeah you keep talking i will i will
search on truth tsar
i think czar would probably cover it
did you find it no i mean unless they're
spelling it
the russian way they are i believe no
no either of the ways that i would spell
different articles okay different
article
um okay that's it i just wanted to call
people's attention to the uh
fact that um encrypted chat is uh
the next frontier in uh rights
elimination yep
great uh well from there there's no
natural i couldn't figure out
where that should go relative to
anything else we're going to talk about
so another unnatural segue to talking
about uh the nature of the null
hypothesis
you ready yeah okay so this is this is
an observation that you made
this week um and just to let your brain
switch gears here i'll
slowly set you up here in general if a
new virus emerges
um the it seems like the null hypothesis
um that is to say the default hypothesis
that is to say the thing that is most
likely to be true
absent evidence the contrary is that it
is a natural origin
right and that seems to be although i've
never seen anyone say that
in this year that we've been living with
this um that seems to be sort of implied
in a lot of the arguments you know
extraordinary ideas extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence what's
your evidence for lab leak
as if um the you know pangolin
mediated wet market story
uh is a parsimonious null hypothesis
which frankly it never was
um and you came to dinner maybe one time
this week and said okay that but maybe
in this case
natural origin should not be the null
hypothesis yeah i mean
i'm not saying it should or it shouldn't
but the point is the assumption that it
should is obviously
uh absurd i do want to go back and say i
heard eric say on clubhouse last night
something that i have uh often said
myself i don't know if i've said it on
dark horse but
this idea of extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence
not a scientific principle right in fact
the rules of engagement are perfectly
clear
right and the point is i don't care how
extraordinary the claim is
is you know is the hypothesis better
supported by
the evidence and are there any other
hypotheses if not it's a theory
if it is better supported but there are
other viable hypotheses than it is one
it is the best supported hypothesis but
yeah
i i hope you could detect the mockery in
my in my language when i said that but
it is one of these things that trotted
out as if it's a scientific rejoinder to
something you said well
scientific claims require a sign
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence
right inherently no and
if correlation is not evidence of
causation
what is so this little brain teaser
correlation is in fact evidence of
causation if there was a causal
hypothesis pre-existing the observation
of the correlation
correlation sorry correlation is
evidence of causation when preceded
by hypothesis that predicted the
correlation yep
i mean that's that's it right yep that
is it so in any case they're all of
these little landmines distributed
across the landscape but in this case so
we're going to get in trouble as
always happens when i talk about null
hypothesis in this informal
um philosophical way because
null hypothesis has a very narrow
definition with respect to
a statistical test and in this case i'm
not talking about a statistical test
what i'm talking about is the default
assumption right
we can say the default assumption for a
new
virus is that it emerged uh you know
zoonotically right now that's not
necessarily true because we could say is
that true
for new york right if i see a new virus
that i haven't seen in my clinic in new
york
is the default assumption that it has
emerged from
an animal here in new york no the
default is assumption
assumption is it probably came in at the
airport or the train station or over one
of the bridges or something like that it
came from somewhere else so the point is
you could make the argument of the
default hypothesis
uh would be zoonotic emergence but in
that case no there's a
more uh there's a clearly more likely
possibility in any locale
well yeah it's a zodonic emergence but
with an additional step added
to account for the geographic
unlikelihood
of a you know of a spillover event in
the middle of a major city
right which gets to the analogy that i
came to dinner
shaking my fist at the air uh about
which was this and i
i haven't been to a circus in a very
long time
i hope they no longer use bears but the
idea of the analogy is
were you let's say in downtown dallas
maybe you're at the uh you're at the
target you're in the target parking lot
and the circus is in town
and a bear wanders by right
you could say that the null hypothesis
is that the bear has
emerged from nature but there are no
grizzlies in
um in texas at this point and
there is a circus and it might have
bears the obvious
first assumption and the one that any
rational person knowing the circus was
in town and having seen a bear walk
across the parking lot
would make is maybe the bear got away
from the circus or the zoo right
and the point about this is in the case
of the wuhan institute of virology we
have this exact
case it's more subtle because you can't
see viruses and so
where they are and aren't isn't familiar
but we don't have
these beta coronaviruses circulating in
horseshoe bats near wuhan
right they're a thousand kilometers away
in yunnan
right what we do have in wuhan is an
institute that brings those viruses
in to study them right and so the point
is
we have been sold the idea that the uh
the burden of proof is on the hypothesis
that suggests
anything other than zoonotic emergence
but in this case there's a strong
argument to be made
that standing in wuhan and observing
this pandemic
break out that actually the default
assumption
probably is that it came from the place
in wuhan where these viruses actually
are known to exist
and not um that it is uh
zoonotic in origin and previously
undetected in any case
i'm not going to say that is but i'm
going to say
the uh the the argument that is deployed
that obviously
this um the hypothesis that the virus
came from the wuhan ins institute is so
extraordinary that it requires
um overwhelming evidence before we even
begin to talk about it
is nonsense it's clearly one of the
hypotheses that belongs on the table
i would argue that the one with the
burden of proof
is the is the more extraordinary of them
which in this case
it would be that a you know zoonotic
emergence happened without our detection
refined the virus turned it into an uh a
virus that transmits
very well between human beings and then
suddenly showed up without leaving any
evidence that we can see
uh in wuhan right near the wuhan
institute
yeah so you're in fact arguing that the
loudly hypothesis sort of has some
parsimony already built in
on the basis of um some of the evidence
that we can see even without the help of
any of the potential players on the
ground there and it looks like we're not
likely to get any help from the
potential players on the ground there so
um the evidence is going to require some
sleuthing but
um it seems more parsimonious
at from the starting gate well it seems
more parsimonious from the starting gate
and we now have a history it's not a
real long history
right we're talking about one year but
you know we had these hypotheses
traveling in parallel and yes one of
them faced a whole hell of a lot of
stigma
that one remains consistent with all of
the evidence that has accumulated
in the intervening period you know what
has not
the um natural origins hypothesis
you know involved a story that now uh is
strongly suspect on at least two counts
right the
the wet market and the pangolins so um
the point is
over time one of these hypotheses is
getting stronger one of them is getting
weaker
and you know doesn't mean it couldn't
turn around tomorrow but
um you know at some level
it was clearly a hypothesis in native
testing
and those who tried to shut it down did
the world no service
i guess i want to try to be a little
maybe a little bit more careful than
that because i don't think that that is
the
that is the fair comparison between the
two hypotheses that
lab leak from
one of the labs in wuhan
leaves a lot of the details on un
described
right and there are several that we have
talked about ourselves and sometimes
publicly
and it could go a lot of different ways
you know it could be gain of function it
could like it
there could be a lot of particulars
there and
natural zoonotic spillover event is i
think
more appropriately the right comparison
so what we were sold
you know a year ago was you know wuhan
wet market and pangolin and that had a
high level of specificity which is part
of why it seemed like oh well
scientists know it's pangolin wow what
are the chances right
but you know so the details of the thing
that was sold to us
um inappropriately um so strongly early
on have fallen by the wayside but i
would say that we that really
you know to compare similar type similar
like levels of granularity of hypotheses
we want like lab leak and natural
zoonotic spill over
and i know i still agree with you i
think you know lab leak looks like
it is more appropriate the null
hypothesis here um but loudly compared
to
you know wuhan wet market spillover from
horseshoe bat to
pangolin to human um is unfairly
stacking the deck against that
as a possibility yup i mean i take your
point and i think philosophically it's
the right one which is that you need to
compare
uh things of similar levels of precision
yeah um
but at some level the way i would do
that is i would say
um you know lab leak is a cluster
of hypotheses as people saw on the
diagram that i put up
as is zoonotic spillover yes and
the um
the question is does anything
in zone a stand up yeah if
lab leak is zone 8 does anything in zone
a remain consistent with all of the
information that we have
as of this date and then we can do the
same trick over here of all the kinds of
zoonotic spillover is anything still
completely consistent
and the problem is that the
things within zoonotic spillover that
are completely consistent with
everything we know so far would have to
be extraordinary
i think that's the thing that uh has me
animated is that you could tell a story
that would explain every piece of data
that we have about uh sars cov2
that would be consistent with zoonotic
spillover but it'd be quite a story and
the chances that it happened without
leaving any evidence that we would have
yet found even though the chinese at
least are feeling tremendous pressure to
find a zoonotic explanation
seems very unlikely again nothing here
is conclusive
but in terms of figuring out how to feel
about it
to the extent that you've been brow
beaten into believing
that those who talk about lab leaks
are wild-eyed oh sorry we need to cover
this i think
okay um it turns out we have learned in
talking bravely about this
question that there is a
misunderstanding
amongst people who evaluate these
various possibilities and that the deck
has weirdly been stacked against the
idea of lab leak because people think
what is being suggested is much more
extraordinary
than what is actually likely to have
happened so
to the extent that people when they hear
did the virus come from a lab and they
imagine that the allegation has
something to do
with this virus having been assembled in
a lab
for a purpose right that it's either a
completely synthetic
virus or you know that it was built up
like lego-wise and it's not that that's
not a component
right we have chimerism which can be
used to take strains from one
naturally occurring virus and strains
from another naturally occurring virus
and put them into a single virus that
has both strengths right but i've not
seen
anyone compellingly argue that this was
created from scratch there is a it
originally in a
bat virus backbone to this thing no
matter what right maybe it's entirely
bat virus with spillover
maybe it's bat virus backbone but this
other thing
that some people are coming back at us
anyway and saying like are you kidding
me
um like no literally no one as far as i
can tell
seriously proposing that right literally
no one no it's overwhelmingly similar to
ratg13
which turns out to be four nine nine one
which is another piece of evidence that
something fishy is going on here
again described exactly what was ridley
and chan paper that we'll link to
right which typical people should read
but the point is what is being
hypothesized with respect to a lab leak
is not out of the range
of what we know was going on in the
wuhan
institute in other words these
techniques are known they're
extraordinary but
extraordinary does not mean that we are
guessing we actually know because they
published
the various labs involved in this work
published
reports on what they were doing so we
know that all of these techniques exist
we know that they were being applied but
i mean i guess again to get back to like
well what do evolutionary biologists
have to say about this like the nature
of this research is precisely
we are going to pass the virus through
different selective environments
and see what pops out it is not
conclusion driven it is not like we are
trying to get to there maybe
maybe they're trying to but there's it's
actually like hands off let's see
what mutations pop out and what sticks
and you know that that is exactly
evolutionary
evolutionary process like it is there is
no other way to describe it
and the i think the uncareful
unnuanced image that people have in
their heads that unfortunately many
virologists many people doing this kind
of research are happy to have people
imagine
is oh you've got a technique and so you
know that when you want to have virus a
with b
in it you just go chunk and like yes
there is some of that there is some of
the chimerism
um chimerism but the gain of function
research
the serial passaging is not like that it
does
exactly produce results that you cannot
completely control
not only not completely control but
effectively evolution is being used to
do things that we don't yet know how to
do
exactly so um and we don't know what
we'll get and we don't know what all the
effects will be
and we have no way to control them if
they happen
so the importance of this
would be hard to overstate now you
mentioned i think
i think you actually mixed two papers
there's a lancet paper and a
nature paper that both showed up very
early to
shut down any inquiry into the idea of
lab labels the lancet paper was like the
many many signatories you're right with
dasic on it
the nature paper made
the following argument it made the
argument
that although the um
the receptor binding domain of sars cov2
is very well adapted to bind the protein
in question
we did not know enough to make the
protein that way
anybody who knew what they were doing
would not have made the protein
this way therefore it must be natural
yes which
is a nonsense argument in light of the
fact that you've got gain of function
research
to accomplish what you wouldn't know to
ask for precisely so question are the
scientists doing this research
that confused about the research they
are doing that they themselves
don't recognize the power of what they
are doing and how it works
or are they being intentionally
deceitful either way
either way you need people who actually
understand the tools that they're using
and the implications
um if they're going to be do allowed to
do this kind of research at all again
remember there was a moratorium on this
research in the u.s
from for four years just lifted at the
beginning of the trump administration
and that that claim
i'm sure i don't know where it was
picked up but i'm sure that was part of
what contributed to the
see there's no way this could be lab
league we don't know enough to do that
yes but you know what we do know how to
do we know how to play god well enough
to set evolution on a problem and say
go to it yeah sick it evolution and it
and it happens
and we do we cannot predict what's going
to happen downstream
so in effect what we have is
a piece of non-evidence the fact that
we could not have specified in advance
the um the sequence that we wanted or
that nobody who knew a lot about this
would have specified it because it would
have sounded like it wouldn't have
worked very well
yeah and it was actually it was that
even weaker claim actually
no one would have done this right no
reasonable person would have done this
well
no we're not saying any reasonable
person did it we're saying evolution is
cleverer than reasonable people
and um you know so but here's the thing
the paper i believe it's christian
anderson's paper
in nature is still used to silence
people who say the lab leak hypothesis
is viable
right the fact of there being a paper in
a
major journal peer-reviewed that claims
that this is
rock solid evidence doesn't matter that
it has been
it has been illustrated to be nonsense
because it is not responsive to what
actually is
imagined to have happened right um
that's a very important fact
yes all right
um boy it's like an hour and a half we
got um
sony camera and we got snakes and
mangroves oh my goodness
all right should we do it yeah okay um
sony totally different totally different
sony viruses a new
deeply secret camera this week i guess
the sony alpha one and it's a doozy but
anyway i was watching a doozy in a good
way yeah it's a it's
well here's the thing camera so for
those who don't know and
maybe most of you don't brett's a
brett's a camera guy
well yeah i i have been shooting since i
was in high school
and i i do nature photography is
primarily what i do but
um in any case i pay attention to
cameras and i've noticed some things one
thing i've noticed
is that cameras have gotten incredibly
capable
and that if you look at the rate at
which they are getting
more capable it's approximately the rate
at which the earth is getting
uglier and less interesting that's
unfortunate troubling yes
um but anyway they're getting great so
you know shoot it while it's still
better to document the end
right exactly exactly but anyway sony
released this amazing
uh piece of technology um
this uh alpha one camera and there are a
bunch of reviews because it's really you
know
it pushes the envelope in many ways but
i noticed in one review
zach can you show the uh this is from uh
tony northrup's review of the
sony alpha one here um by the way
tony tony's great does amazing work um
but here he reveals that their new eye
autofocus which is um eye autofocus is a
great thing if you're in nature
photography because the camera
knows enough about what it's looking at
to keep you focused right on the eye
which
is a huge benefit but so for those
listening who can't see the screen what
what are the options for the options for
eye
autofocus are human animal
and bird and i really don't want to hold
them
to uh an absurd standard obviously
humans are animals but i wouldn't expect
you know if the thing said human and
animal that would be fine that
distinction is
intuitive we all we all understand and
you know those of us who traffic
in this sort of thing tend to say humans
and non-human animals we're making that
distinction but that's wordy there's no
room for that here
it doesn't need to be on a menu that way
the problem though
is the distinction between animal and
bird and this is something you and i run
into
in all kinds of circles where it's going
to seem like a little
micro pet peeve that you know only
people like us would care about petty
except i can prove it's not petty in
this case
so the problem is that birds are of
course
well like i want to actually add you
know we aren't teaching here we don't
have an ability to like
get a feeling for the room but like what
do you think a bird is
like what is it is it a rock it's
clearly an animal is it a cruciferous
vegetable like what is it
right if it's not an animal so i think
this comes
and it actually would i'd be curious if
this same conflation happens
in other languages because i think this
has to do just with the fact that
mammal and animal
that causes people to think animal and
mammal or maybe because most of the
animals that they interact with and
think about are
mammals you know the pets the farm
animals and all of this
but in any case the problem is and why i
say i can prove that this matters
is that actually i don't know how to
operate the camera
with those menus with those choices
right because
i want to focus on the eye that's true
irrespective of what kind of animal
i'm focused on if it's a human i got it
right
if it's a non-human animal okay
it's quite possible algorithmically
speaking that birds are special
algorithmically and therefore birds are
a unique category of animal and that
if i'm looking at a lizard
or a uh a dragonfly
that the algorithm will actually work
correctly if i have it set
uh to animal but we don't know what the
algorithm is
right and so phylogenetically yeah
a bird is more closely related to a
lizard
than it is to us right okay but
a bird and a mammal a bird in us
human and bird are equally close as
closely related to a dragonfly
yeah like we're no more close related to
a dragonfly or more distantly related to
dragonfly than a bird is
because we have a most recent common
ancestor that is between
us and dragonfly sort of evolutionary
speaking so
my guess would be not knowing anything
about their algorithm that
like if i was shooting a lizard i'd go
with the bird one
but just because it's going to be kind
like but a dragonfly i have no idea what
i don't
i think the problem is we can't know so
first of all
um people take more photographs than
ever cam
sure photography is more popular than it
has ever been and the camera can
camera industry is dying because uh
by and large cell phones have gotten so
good at this job that you only need
a dslr for certain things one of those
things is nature photography
right a lot of the people who do nature
photography are bird specialists
right so it is not surprising i think
birds are
weird enough looking and uh and
challenging and
challenging they're often far away they
have this nasty habit of flying away
from you
right but it's not surprising to me at
all that the algorithm would break birds
out from everything else i would not be
shocked if actually
a lizard or a salamander uh was closer
in algorithm space to a dog um i would
also not be
terribly surprised if what they mean is
although again salamander is actually
equally disrelated to humans and birds
right lizards but you know all they care
about
so what they care about is that the
algorithm finds the eye
what i care about is that i know what to
set it on right in order to take the
picture i want to take
and these things are very badly
documented so i don't know if there is
no setting
for a lizard or a salamander if it's in
animal and bird is a special category
both human and bird are
um or if animal is all the everything
else
all the other animals that aren't humans
or birds
yeah right so anyway the way you say
this
because so many people get into this
puzzle you know you could say birds and
other animals there's nothing wrong with
saying birds and other animals
birds and other animals is correct but
you don't want to see it say birds and
animals
right birds and animals is i mean for
one thing please don't it just drives us
crazy
it really drives us crazy to hear that
but i do think asking people what they
think they are then yeah like
okay so what what is a bird then right
if you've got that if you've got this
collection of birds and animals
what are they i mean that question gets
tougher at like you know sponges
and things um i don't see a sponge
option right on the sodium exactly but
the point is it's actually you know
people have to stop and think if you say
that about an insect
you know is it an animal yeah it's a fly
an animal
yeah it has to be what else would it be
but you know it takes people
a little bit to get there and i get it
that's it's fine but anyway they should
they should correct
us the only saving grace of this story
is that the camera is so expensive that
this is a completely academic question i
don't have to interact with that menu
you never will right although sony if
you wanted to fix that problem i would
be uh
you would okay i'd be i'd be willing
yeah oh you're so generous yes
very generous by nature all right
um snakes and mangroves
okay let's do snakes first all right um
this question
comes to us from the quest from from the
perspective of
how many ways that snakes move around in
the world um
so here we this is an old site but it's
a site of a friend of ours zach if you
would show this
this is brad moon um who we went to grad
school with awesome
um awesome researchers specifically
focusing on i mean lots of stuff but
biomechanics of snake locomotion
is a big part of his uh his research and
this is um
again this is literally from like a 2001
you can see it was
updated in 2001 so that explains why it
looks like it's from
2001. um but he's just describing like
five types of snake locomotion
and you have most snakes move in
in what is called lateral undulation
just you know this
just slowly back and forth right
traditional
snake motion traditional snake motion
you also have
um concertina motion where they sort of
they
do that and they sort of like back
themselves up and then they like
go forward um i don't know how to do
this for for the
sound sort of thematically a little bit
like a caterpillar
yeah yeah yeah um and you have
rectilinear where they're just somehow
moving straight
and boy did we want to see this happen
in
costa rica our first research season
god what was it some so pelote zopolote
it was a
freaking gigantic fast-moving black
snake that came out of
nowhere it's a snake that hunts
poisonous snakes and they're
one of my friends described them as all
piss and vinegar it's a
very scary snake that actually has a
hood that runs the opposite direction of
a
um cobra hood it's a very amazing animal
wow so it's like a it's like an
a and a gamut or something like a lizard
anyway anyway we saw this snake
just come out of nowhere and did it go
up or down a tree it came out up a tree
tree yeah yeah um and then um slide
pushing is another thing but the but
the maybe the slide pushing um
i didn't actually remind myself it it
doesn't have a sidewinder no
so my point is let's just skip slide
bushing for the moment
because it's one that most people aren't
going to be particularly
um familiar with sidewinding is probably
the second most
common kind of snake locomotion that
people think of even though most of us
including myself
have never seen it i'd love to see
sidewinders
in the wild you can give me my screen
back now zach
thank you um and
um a new york times article from this
week
which reports out on a paper that i
actually can't find even with
our awesome access at the moment to
princeton's university um library but
it's
it's a reason at all 2021 paper from
pnas from proceedings of the national
academy of sciences
called functional consequences of
convergently evolved microscopic sin
skin features on snake locomotion okay
rather than go there we are going to go
to
hold on this article
the skin deep physics of sidewinder
snakes i'm just going to read
read two paragraphs here as we know
from okay hold on actually zach can you
give me back my screen for just a second
yeah these are the two paragraphs i
wanted to read okay as we know from
trying to move on sand in a beach or
other places it could be difficult to
move on these materials yield underneath
you as you move forward
said jennifer reiser a professor of
physics at emory university in atlanta
interesting incidentally that's a
physics professor rather than
biomechanics functional morphology bio
person doing this
that's why sidewinders slither sideways
although some snakes can move laterally
under certain conditions dr reiser said
sidewinders
the common name for a group of three
distantly related vipers
um wait wait does that mean that the
side winding is convergently evolved
yeah hell yeah isn't that awesome okay
so that we're gonna get back to that
um the sidewinders the common name for a
group of three distantly related vipers
found in the deserts of africa the
middle east and north america
have raised this unique form of movement
to an art the sidewinding rattlesnake
for example
can travel at speeds of 18 miles per
hour
making it the fastest snake in the world
so i love snakes but that's terrifying
like that's a that's a
fast sidewinding snake that's going to
come at you so it's not the fastest
snake in the world
um okay who is the flying snake
i mean it depends on how fast it it
drops from yeah how high the tree is
but i mean i'm just saying you know so
there are actually
i used to use in my vertebral evolution
lectures on snakes
um some of the videos that he had of
snakes that were quote unquote flying
and they're not really flying they
aren't volunteering they don't get left
but they glide and they have you know
surfaces that allow them to sort of
um sort of steer and you know maybe um i
should ask him if i can
if i could show them in a future uh
episode um
i'm sure i could anyway um so they don't
don't don't worry guys
they're not actually flying but oh
they're plenty worrying
i mean i think they're charming i think
they're wonderful
but um yeah you have to get the i don't
know what terminal velocity for a
so-called flying snake
is um so you're you're okay
it's got to be faster than sidewinding
but anyway yeah i mean
terminal velocity such that they then
don't die upon landing
right obviously terminal velocity that
isn't terminal yeah i guess it's not
terminal velocity okay
um okay so what this is not the mangrove
angle yet but
like what do you think they do how do
they manage it how do they go so fast
no how do they sidewind how given
that like a rattlesnake can't sidewind
and sidewinders apparently don't do
quite as well
doing the lateral undulation thing
that say rattlesnake does and i'm just
picking rattlesnake because
um they're relatively closely related
you know i could pick i could pick
anything um any
any thoughts on what they might be doing
so you said rattlesnakes can't
sideway aside from sidewinding
rattlesnakes you mean
aside from the three snakes that we call
sidewinders yeah so
okay um like a timber rattlesnake or
something
how do they do it well i'm i'm i'm
thinking it through here and i
really need a few minutes of the piece
of paper does it have something to do
with the rolling of the particles of the
sand
uh i you know i think i think it is
going to have something to do with that
actually so again i couldn't access the
full paper so i'm just going off the
abstract of the paper in the new york
times
piece here but um check
this out here we have
two micrographs of on the left a skin of
the
skin this is the underbelly the ventral
skin of the saharan sand viper
and on the right we have a micrograph of
the inventor
of the belly inventor of the belly the
venter of a mexican
lance-headed rattlesnake and there are
spikes
in the scales um and there might this is
a i think it's an scm although they
don't say a scanning electron micrograph
of um they're little tiny scales that
basically hook
and provide the friction that allows the
lateral insulation of most snakes
which is what we see here on the right
with these little tiny hooks and on the
left you have rather than hooks you
actually have
pits you have little tiny pits not to be
confused like the pits of pit vipers
but little tiny pits in the in the belly
and it's totally smooth
and presumably and again i can't see the
original paper yet
um there are other surfaces to which
they can grab at all
um so i'm i'm still not sure i
understand
these both of these images are from
different clades of sidewinders
no no this is this is a regular lateral
on the right we have a lateral laterally
undulating so inside
of that standard pattern which somehow
i've never seen before
there are little pits that grab
individual grains of sand
uh you know the the how do they make it
work
um is not described and i think it's
actually not about grabbing individual
grains of sand but rather not being
trapped by those individual grains of
sand that if you had
these little hooks that were going in
the same direction as your body
if you're trying to go sideways you get
stuck right you
you would not be able to go sideways
whereas if you have these pits
you now should be able to move equally
well in any direction and presumably not
as well going forward
as a snake with the hooks on the bottom
cool right so
i think that's super cool um in part
because i like snakes but also because
you still haven't told us what the
mangroves are doing exactly
so um
i think maybe the most interesting thing
here isn't the snakes but the
convergence
like sidewinding evolved three different
times in
um in cortalids in in pit vipers
and this put me in the mind of mangroves
yep yes so mangrove
is also a convergent category
there is not an evolution of mangroves
and then we see them in various places
all over the world
it's a an adaptation to a
problem to you know it's a solution to a
problem that the
animal has encountered so just like
three sidewinding snakes
exist in in environments where they have
very loose substrate
mangroves have evolved several times in
the world
um in uh in places where
um there is either regular flooding and
or um a lot of salinity in the water
you called them you called them animals
which i think is cool i think they've
earned it did i call the mangroves
animals yes you did
cool okay birds aren't but mangroves are
there it is um okay so um
i want to just read this is from a piece
that i wrote
um i posted on my patreon a few years
ago
about the fabulous field station
navapatia
down near the sonora sinaloa border on
the
mainland of mexico looking west towards
the sea of cortez
which steve herbin steve herman who was
an extraordinary naturalist and
orthologist who died last year who was
one of the nearly founding
faculty members at evergreen who you
described on a prior
who i talked about actually i think it
was episode 17 i had i had recently
heard of his death and um i i gave
homage to him he really was
extraordinary and he was i was actually
hired
to quote unquote replace him often
faculty positions are like that and um
he was people described him as prickly
and um
i think he was just fed up with the
stupidity that was rife in almost
everyone and um
he liked to be pushed he like right away
upon meeting him i was
um willing to disagree with him and he
adored that which actually is the sign
of a an excellent scientist right
so um he uh had found this place
that is now called navapatia many many
many years ago and at one point early on
a student of his adam haniksala
was going down with him and he took um
steve's daughter sally sally herman down
she is a botanist
and um to surprise tea for his birthday
anyway long story short which i
described some of in this piece
um adam and sally for many years ran
navapati it was a labor of love
and it was i was i was lucky enough to
spend
i don't even remember like just 10 12
days or something down there many years
ago
with adam and sally and several
evergreen students
um and it's just it's a it's a glorious
place unlike any place else and actually
i believe
i believe that our former student mike
krizwiki is now running navapatia um
and that um it is it's fabulous and it's
open
for people to you don't have to be an
active researcher to go down there so
you know we have a standing invitation
and
you know i encourage people to look it
up um but the very i give all of that
background
in a conversation that was supposed to
be about snakes and sidewinders
um to make sense of this third from the
last paragraph of this piece
on my last full day at navopatia sally
herrmann leads me through the mangrove
labyrinth on the island
we paddle over then mostly pull
ourselves through holding prop roots and
branches
gliding looking emerging into an inner
lagoon
then to a hidden exit through more
mangrove here there are three species of
mangrove they look different and
accomplish what they do in different
ways
but by virtue of their shared habit of
having their roots immersed in the tidal
zone
and having therefore to pull saltwater
in and convert it to fresh
we give them all the name mangrove but
oh again the problem of names
in this case that word mangrove reflects
shared solutions to shared problems
without reflecting shared history
there are at least 36 unique plant
families in which mangroves have been
identified
and those families are generally not
entirely made up of mangrove forms
to be a mangrove is to be convergent
with many others not of your own kind
not of your lineage but others who have
encountered a problem
there is salt in this water all the time
and also the trade-off on the other side
of that problem
there are a few other plants here few
who could compete with me if only i
could figure out how to clear the salt
from my system
and so mangrove the strategy evolved
many times over
in many places around the coasts of the
world
so there is lifetimes to say about
convergence
but the connection there is
mangroves i mean this this is i did not
go back and um
see what the current phylogenetic
thinking is so that was the current
phytogenic thinking as of
whatever three or four years ago but 36
times yeah the mangrove habit has
evolved in the world 36 times
that's amazing um i will say
of convergence this that
if not for convergence everything
in evolution would be a single data
point and we would have no idea what's
going on
and so i think convergence is in many
ways the most beautiful
of evolutionary processes because when
you see evolution do the same trick
twice you know an awful lot about what's
going on that you couldn't say for sure
you know in fact things like um feathers
right you would think that the evolution
of feathers would be a straightforward
thing to explain and in fact it's not
there i don't haven't checked in on this
recently but there are multiple
hypotheses for the evolution of feathers
and it's very difficult to sort out
because feathers have arisen exactly
once
and um asterisk which will intrigue like
two of our viewers
the order in which feathers endothermy
and flight and arboreality evolved
in um basal birds is actually a
contentious issue
so um you might imagine that flight was
you know that flight couldn't have
happened before like
that some of these things are inherently
true but actually it's it's a live
debate
yep so anyway it's a it's a beautiful
process
and uh thank goodness for it and i just
the final little piece of that is that
there are two
parts to evolutionary biology and they
are really
mirror images almost exactly right so
you have phylogenetic thinking where you
try to figure out what's related to
to what right and then you have adaptive
thinking
which is why does it look that way right
why does it behave that way
and in order to have any idea why it
looks or behaves that way
you have to have a phylogeny that allows
you to see who's actually related to
whom
in spite of who seems to be related to
whom and in order to do the phylogenetic
work correctly
you have to swamp out the
false signal that comes from convergence
which they call
homoplasy and define as an error and
it's like okay noise
you've just taken the most beautiful
process in evolution and you've called
it
error because it gets in the because it
fools you and you don't like it which i
understand but nonetheless in some ways
these you know you would think evolution
was one discipline and it's really like
two disciplines that meet at an
uncomfortable border
yeah and we have history in both of
those traditions but
and the best um you know in
as in any field and for anyone the more
specialized you are the harder it is to
see across the gap
to see across into places that you don't
have deep familiarity
um but our two advisors um and we really
both
both worked with both of them um but on
paper
um dick alexander was your advisor and
he was on my committee but arnold
cloughey was my advisor and dick
alexander
you know knew deep things about
phylogenyx systematics but he was in no
way a systematist he was a he was a
micro guy he was a
behavior and population level processes
guy and arnold kluge
was a deep history guy who also actually
published a monograph
based on like almost a year studying the
um oh boy studying
frogs in the canal zone in panama i
can't remember at the moment which
clayton it was
um and i'll kick myself and that's
gladiator frogs that's building
frogs yeah pipeline road on pipeline
road yeah
but but he you know he made his name for
himself and he was you know
he still is alive a towering figure in
in systematics
doing the deep history stuff and um i
remember going to him at one point late
in in my dissertation um after having
heard him sort of
rail against you know finding
convergence places where
it was really irritating to find it
going like uh dr kluge
this you know this is entirely what i'm
doing you know this this is my work and
i'm your student and
you know d are you in fact finding um
finding what i'm doing nothing but error
nothing but noise
and you know he to his enduring credit
he was shocked at the question right
it's like no you're
you're doing terrific work it's not
phylogenetic work
that's it's different so where you are
spending time you said to me
um what would be noise to me as pattern
for you
and vice versa and you know that that is
one of the
the additional truths about doing
science is that depending on where
you're standing what questions you're
asking
the things that you're trying to like
reduce um
to the level of um i don't need to pay
attention to that might be exactly the
things
that other people are trying to rise up
to the surface to try to explain
yeah in fact um noise is completely
defined with reference to what you're
studying right it's all a pattern of one
kind or another
right um but uh yeah noise is um
it's confounding literally but um
yeah all right um we're there we are
there do we want to show
the thumbnail picture for this week or
just have it be up oh maybe quickly okay
zachary if you can do that
all right so we
are going to change up our thumbnail
game because
pictures of us behind this desk all look
alike more or less so
we are going to try to use a new photo
we're setting the challenge of finding a
photo that we take
each week of something worth
photographing um
and this is your photo heather you want
to say what it is yeah just
um i the the the night sky the
sky at dusk last night was extraordinary
sure was and you went out on your bike
and i went out on a walk
um and the it had been dark and dreary
and rainy all day and it cleared with
high fluffy clouds
right about you know half an hour before
sunset through
half an hour after sunset at which point
you couldn't tell anymore um
and um
on this walk i found myself approaching
this tunnel
and it i guess it struck both of us as
potentially appropriate to use as a
thumbnail
um as you know you can't it looks like
what's at
the other side of the tunnel is the same
thing as what is on this side
um but you can't totally tell and you
just you know there are a lot
there are a lot of such paths that we
are all finding ourselves on
right now uh that well do i turn back or
do i just go through the tunnel and see
what happens next
and i would say in general we should be
going through the tunnels yep
so this has some meaning for me because
uh the kids and i had
played around in this park on this trail
system
um and anyway so uh
i think i had mentioned it to you at
some point long enough ago that you
hadn't remembered that i'd mentioned it
and so you came back excited about this
i discovered this park i had no idea
existed right and so you know and a
little a few questions later it became
clear
i discovered it you discovered it yes in
rather the same way that cristobal
cologne discovered
the america totally very much like
exactly that sort of discovery
but anyway it is sort of interesting a
um to have you
happen onto this place that had really
struck us many months ago
yeah um and you know then to discover
that it was the same place and even just
the weird human fact of like
you know if we didn't have language we
could have
been there many months ago and then you
could have ended up there today and
there'd be no
mechanism for exchanging the information
or comparing notes
but anyway it ain't like that yeah it's
not like that
so okay um we are going to take a 15
minute break
if you are on youtube we encourage you
to join us after that for
live fire q a we'll be answering
questions from super chat
if you are listening to the podcast
we'll be back in a week
um before then though uh for um
for both youtube watchers and podcast
listeners there will be an additional
episode of dark horse that brett is
doing that brett has recorded that will
be up
uh maybe tuesday wednesday of this week
with i say
sure with daniel schmucktenberger um
should be a terrific conversation well
it was a great conversation it was a
terrific conversation only you and
daniel know that at this point
i guess zack i think we were both pretty
jazzed on it excellent
so uh daniel is a friend of ours he's
fabulous and we encourage
everyone to listen to that as well we
will be back as usual 12 30
uh pacific saturday next week
uh please consider supporting us at
either of our patreons mine heather hein
has the dark horse membership where you
can get access to the
once a month private q a which we leave
up as a link after
so even if you can't join us live you
can you can watch it's a two-hour q a
we do not guarantee that the answers
remain
true yes there's a
there's a statute of limitations on the
veracity of the answers
there is very short it's not the right
that's not the right description
no um you have
uh conversations at your patreon
including uh tomorrow morning
tomorrow it has been moved one hour
earlier than has been our tradition
to nine o'clock nine to 11 on uh
on sunday um on either of your patreons
at
um at five dollars or more per month you
can get access to the discord where
there is an ongoing
a lively conversation i hear um there is
also i think it is now
safe to say that we are also i have done
one
uh where i drop in and do a q a there
maybe you will join me for one of those
in the future but i will certainly head
back and do that i think you're actually
on the schedule for next week sometime i
believe that is true yeah
um you can you can get your first
against the wall club and
other merchandise and we'll be coming
out with something new again soon at
starstore.darkhorsepodcast.org
uh and maybe that's about it that could
be it that could be it okay we'll be
back in 15 minutes
for some of you and a week for the rest
of you get outside
yes immediately
[Music]
you